[Music]
as we mark five years since one October
we'll also be taking part in the fifth
annual Vegas strong 5K the Vegas strong
5K event brings people together every
October to help make our community
stronger it inspires our young people to
be Vegas Strong by investing in their
education
just seven weeks after the one October
shooting the first Vegas strong 5K hit
the pavement raising money for those
still reeling with pain and loss and now
five years strong the event has become
an annual reunion people want to be here
they want to come together and Remember
Las Vegas local and organizer Cynthia
Gainey uses her running event company
just run to bring thousands together
each October to run and walk the road to
Healing this year registrations are from
across the country and Canada and as far
away as Europe people kept saying we
want this to continue every year every
year and I said I will continue to put
it on as long as people want it 100 of
the proceeds go to victims funds and
scholarship programs for Las Vegas
students like Maggie Louie now a junior
at UNLV I think it's just part of your
own
passion to like save people Louie is
studying to become a doctor she says her
scholarship alleviates a lot of the
financial burden for her to become a
first responder so she can be part of a
positive change you see that more people
are caring about each other in a way
that's like how are you doing like are
you okay and I think the community is
more united in that way we see these
Scholarships in combination with all the
other services that are happening across
our community as one of the ways that we
can come together and heal and remember
what happened on one October Kirsten
Seer is president of the public
Education Foundation which Awards
various scholarships funded since the
2017 tragedy she says events like the
Vegas strong 5K help Empower our young
people to build a stronger community and
never forget and certainly we're seeing
that in the essays from our students
they're still feeling this and it hasn't
gone away and it probably shouldn't have
gone away we need to we need to remember
it we need to continue to talk about it
and recover together I will naturally
become a part of Vegas strong
and I hope to be able to spread that
message to other people as well we just
continue to do this and everybody's
going to come together and whether you
know somebody or not just come out
um participate and you will feel it
you'll feel the support you'll feel the
love
to date the Vegas strong 5K has raised
about a quarter of a million dollars for
victims funds and scholarships but more
money is needed for some of these
scholarships to continue if you would
like to help you can donate directly to
the public education foundation's
website you see there on your screen
that link
pef.org one October we'll have it on our
website 8newsnow.com as well or sign up
for the Vegas strong 5K right up until
Sunday morning you can use that QR code
on your screen we'll have live coverage
at eight on Sunday morning and Heather
nade and myself along with JC Fernandez
will all be out there at 8 A.M and you
can watch that if you can't make it out
there yourself eight news now we'll be
live on Sunday morning it is going to be
a wonderful wonderful day so